the reductionist mechanistic view of the
mind has a
rather revealing history i think which
is
that whatever the most advanced
technology
currently available the
those who seek to mechanistically marble
the mind
immediately seize upon it and announce
that
the mind is in the 19th century the mind
was actually conceived of as
an intricately wrought piece of
technology analogous to the clockmaker's
art and in the 20s we were told the mind
is like a vast telephone exchange
and in the late 20th century
it's all computers and parallel
processing and this sort of thing
for us the mind is
largely conditioned by the personal past
the shaman's view of mind is that it
is not centered in the human being
mind is a dimension in which
human beings and their environment are
embedded so it isn't a narcissistic
uh model of the mind it isn't my mind
it is the mind it is almost as it were
the invisible part of nature
and so the shaman by inducing altered
states
makes the invisible part of nature
slash mind visible to himself and then
he
as a kind of reality engineer is able to
manipulate the field of mind and
cure disease locate lost objects
predict the weather see where the game
has gone
all of the classical functions of
shamanism
are obtained then in this relationship
to mind
as field what happens under the
influence of these
psychoactive compounds that are products
of plant metabolism
is that the carefully constructed
mental categories and boundaries of
social
convention and experience dissolve
and the cultural map which is a
linguistic
map is replaced by
something most of us haven't known since
our infancy
that is the seamless pre-verbal
feeling-toned continuum of reality
out of which every culture constructs
its own
model and myth these shamans what
they're doing
is they're actually using folk
pharmacology to step outside of the
culturally constructed myth
whatever it is and then they are able to
as it were see the wiring
under the board the wiring of culture
the wiring of familial connections the
way in which
disease impinges on the human group
they are in mercedes wonderful phrase
the technicians of the sacred i think
the
the game of understanding of creating
models is simply that a game
and out of it come various technologies
you know
truth is approached entirely
differently truth is apprehended through
feeling and is known by its
self-evidence it isn't an argument that
one makes
i mean let's not lose hold of the fact
that
we are animals of some sort advanced
primates the notion that we should be
able to
reason or intuit our way to god's
universal truth
is a startlingly parochial idea
it's good mental exercise to make the
attempt
but my brother once said the wonderful
thing he said
have you ever noticed how as we build
the bonfire of understanding
bigger the sphere of the unknown grows
ever larger
and a simple way of saying that is you
know the
more light there is the more darkness
that is revealed
[Music]
[Music]
you